♪ ♪ ♪
TAMARA ALTERESCO, correspondante
de Radio-Canada en Russie
- Le président de ususussie,
Vladimir Poutine, vient de
quitter la scène où il a passé
plus de quatre heures à répondre
aux questions des journalistes.
C'est un eicicice qui est
toujours important à la fin
de l'année, cette conférence de
presse annuelle de M. Poutine.
Mais aujourd'hui, elle l'était
encores,s,s, je vous dirais,
dans les tensions que génèrent
les troupes qui sont massées
à la frontière de l'Ukraine
et cette menace constante depuis
trois semaines, quatre semaines
déjà, d'une invasion russe
en Ukraine. Et la question a été
posée, il y avait des centaine
de journalistes ici :
"Très clairement, M. Poutine,
qu'est-ce que vous préparez?
Qu'est-ce qui se passe
votre tête? Pourquoi? Quand?"
Et il a répondu très clairement,
cette fois-ci, en disant :
"La balle est dansmpmpmpmp
de l'Occident. Nous, on a posé
nos conditions, on veut que
l'OTAN renonce à toute expansion
éventuelle vesesesest."
Donc, y compris, bien sûr,
l'Ukraine, surtout,
je vous dirais. Il dit :
"C'est nocococociable, on veut
des garanties sécuritaires,
on les veut tout de suite,
on les veut maintenant."
Ce qu'il y a d'encourageant
dans ce que tous les
journalistes ont entendu
aujourd'hui, et les Russes
aussi, c'est que M. Poutine
s'est dit agréablement étonné
et surpris de l'ouverture
qu'il sent chez Washington,
donc il y aura des discussio
très possiblement au mois
de janvier, à Genève, entre
la Maison-Blanche et Moscou,
pour justement déterminer
comment l'OTAN peut
à Vladimir Poutine les garanties
qu'il veut pour renoncer
à toute action militaire
en Ukraine. C'est un gros
ieieieieier, c'est un dossier
qui peut exploser à tout moment.
Donc, il va falloir surveiller
ce qui se passe au mois
de janvier. Ça ne veut pas dire,
mais tant et aussi longtemps
qu'il y a espoir de dialogue,
et c'est ce qu'il a confirmé
qu'il y a aujourd'hui,
en conférence de presse, on peut
espérer que ça va se calmer.
Ici Tamara Alteresco,
Radio-Canada, Mosco